[Musique]
grand ce soit pas nerveux t'aurais pas
quelque peu fait pas tout foiré
je t'aime
moi aussi je t'aime on va faire une
fausse aussi
merdique aller grand sourire
mais ça vous dit
[Musique]
mélissa salué philippe voir ça fait un
sacré bout de temps
ça doit vous sembler assez étrange que
je débarque comme ça après toutes ces
années
je n'ai été qu'un accroc ni
la nuit où il est mort il ya cinq ans
sorte d'étrange miracle s'est produit
ce bébé qui beauchamp mois élan fort de
rosny
foule a immédiatement d'or
qu'elle raconte est absolument
impossible tg s'est pas absolument
impossible
est-ce qu'elle avait l'air bien fier
pourquoi tu fais ça
[Musique]
on y aurait aimé que tu veilles sur elle
vous avez toujours un truc
c'est beaucoup plus vaste que tout ce
que vous voyez au santé
je me suis parfois l'allier c'est
vraiment la seule et unique réponse ah
ouais
mais quelle horreur
[Musique]
si nous connaissions la vérité
ce serait moins effrayant
au plus encore
[Musique]